we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50  I'm gonna go next to our caller from the  9 1 9 area code who's calling today from  911 hi I'm Ari I'm hey Ari what's going  on Waltham  where I went to graduate school at a  Bentley University Wrestlemania 35 has  the potential and I want to be really  careful here Ari not to become  hyperbolic WrestleMania 35 has the  potential to completely revolutionize  the fake wrestling world in a way that  could really upend the entire  socio-political conversation happening  in the United States so I am very very  anxiously looking forward to it  but it have already happened so okay  well in that case I missed it all right  Ari thank you very much for the call  appreciate it  listen if you're gonna ask a silly  question you're gonna get a silly answer